you never have this problem with dog
sleds got it see if we'll go all the way
around every year more people are eaten
by snowmobiles than sharks fat half-man
half-machine it's snow mo cop looks like
that son of a bitch Jack Frost turned
this neighborhood into one big game of
shuffleboard
[Applause]
just like a Taylor Swift relationship
this is actually kind of soothing and
beautiful if you put the right music
behind it to be fair putting on tire
chains is a real hassle
you want to steer into the wreck okay
that one wasn't the ices fault that
driver was Asian
[Music]
luckily the happy Honda days sales event
just started my contact fell out there's
no way we're gonna reach the summit
tonight so I'm left with no other choice
I'm gonna have to give myself elective
LASIK eye surgery why don't you just
wear your prescription ski goggles all
right looks stupid in these I should
really make the font bigger in this book
we're only 50 feet away from our car I
can hold your arm you can just walk back
why do you have all that you got to come
prepared 1 2 1 1 1 you only get one shot
at this just gotta stay still for a few
days I'm gonna see the mountain like
never before in two to three weeks
wouldn't you know it after all that I
found my contact it was on my cheek a
person's body should never end up in a
suitcase unless she says something
really crazy any witnesses and they
can't prove motive ok there is not a
snowball's chance in hell this is gonna
work it'd be quicker just to put them
sprayed into a body bag dragging someone
behind a pickup truck in the winter even
makes hate crimes seem whimsical
[Music]
sometimes it's safer just to stay inside
and do drugs kids they should take that
suitcase to the airport and switch it
with one that doesn't have a dead boy in
it he's crying because he's crammed
against the collapsible handle suck it
up your tears are gonna freeze into i'm
being a so cold these guys might
not be smart one that's not a brief case
you're not going to unpack someone with
a spine injury you don't want anybody to
know about this attempted manslaughter
you're about to put on YouTube okay is
there anything funnier than giving your
friend pneumonia but I keep laughing but
his ghost will get you back when you go
waterskiing next summer his perfect
teenage body will be preserved for eons
this is what that Phil Collins song is
about would you know my name
[Music]
you